foreign
people
how's everybody doing
um I was supposed to do this live when
it happened and then I had work so I
couldn't and this is literally my first
chance to catch up so I've just
completely avoided the news uh sorry I
missed it actually live but I'm ready to
catch up looks like it's about 45
minutes I don't know what's in it yet I
know there was one game announced that
everyone's like losing their minds about
decided to find out
and from what it looks like there's a
lot of Elder Scrolls content in here as
in Elder Scrolls Online
also let me know if the audio is okay
hello Susie
um nice time to just you know drink some
tea wine down for the evening
catch up on a conference
[Music]
it seems to me like the sentiment has
been positive but I have no idea
I mean the cars kind of gave that away
but
yeah that's sweet that was Red Bull
that's Elder Scrolls okay this is just
the highlights
Minecraft Legends
[Music]
I realized when I thought previously in
a video when I'd mentioned haven't I
already played that I was talking about
Minecraft dungeons
[Music]
five
that's redacted that's got to be the the
new one everyone's hyped about huh
oh yeah
[Music]
I'm a big Minecraft fan hello I'm Dennis
Reese executive producer of Minecraft
Legends and today we'd like to give you
an Insider's look at how we're building
the PVP multiplayer experience for the
game
Minecraft Legends is a new action
strategy game set in a lush Dynamic
World it introduces epic storytelling
and you can form alliances with new and
familiar Minecraft Mobs to stop the
invading pigments looks like Minecraft
Minecraft Legends will let you play the
story driven campaign
I have investigated with your friends a
YouTube short also feature
two teams with up to four players each
Works to destroy the opponent's team
space
is cool the game will support
cross-platform play and online
in order to create the best possible
experience we partner with Blackbird
interactive to develop the game
and it's been wonderful to see their
commitment and focus on the Minecraft
Universe it doesn't happen it's so much
fun unless they're looking at memes you
know Deb stands around a table and like
Smiles quite attractive we have a
talented team of developers who are
using our background and strategy games
to bring a new and exciting experience
to the Minecraft Universe we're super
excited to share more details about PVP
gameplay
here
right here
looks like they're actually cool
features that make using the unique
first real players share their army and
resources with their Banta and not the
fake individual players aren't able to
win on their own is that Ghostbusters
cooperate to be successful
communication is really important and
you can sort of really tell the teams
that gel together because they naturally
form roles at the beginning of the game
and as soon as we start you're off
collecting I start building we already
we have our favorite roles but we
changed them up
like Heroes also the world in PvP is
procedurally generated just like it is
in campaign
this means that each PVP session is
different than the last
that's good it's different every time
you play depending on how the map is
generated where the valleys are the
mountains are where the secrets are you
know where the towers are
in Minecraft Legends the piglets are an
ever-present threat and this includes
PVP the piglens are on their own side
they're trying to kill both of you at
the same time
so the opposing team is not the only
thing you need to worry about
there's something for everyone
parents who like action they can go
attack the piglets or lay Siege to the
enemy base for players who enjoy
exploration they can search the world to
find resources for their team I mean
I'll definitely try this I'm not really
sure
if I'm gonna like it just yet to help
the team out don't give it a show
important but whenever I get into a PVP
match the first thing I try to do is to
track down the Regal tiger it's my
favorite mob to ride because it's really
fast but it's also really cute a
parakeet for players who like building
you can spend your time building
defenses and upgrading your base because
soon enough your enemy will attack and
you need to be ready
so the first thing I do when we start is
everyone runs off I open the map see
where the enemy base is first thing I
build is what we call an upgrade Tower
which allows you to build upgrade so I
place that in the back away from the
enemy
so I really pride myself in making you
know impenetrables pretty cool
since the goal of PVP is to destroy the
opposing team's base Defending Your Own
base is really important you have to
start with a lot of walls a lot of
towers and some gates well if you have a
PC and after that you can just add
whatever you want for you still
technically have Xbox games
different layers of walls so my
opponents have to find their way through
to my base almost like people saw a way
and then once those walls are up that's
what's gameplay behind them to catch
enemies off guard I'm pretty sure when
it comes time to finally take out the
other team my favorite strategy is to
make a forward Camp just outside the
enemy base then I get the biggest
strongest mobs I can as fast as I can
and start sending them in
then I can smash Down the Walls take out
their mobs and claim victory this just
seems like the kind of game I'm gonna be
real fun of PVP is creating a strategy
having a game plan deciding how you
think you're going to crush the enemy
and then all of a sudden the hosts tell
you
build a redstone launch
and you're like I can't do my attack now
that's pretty cool build an anti-siege
Tower which is an anti-air Tower to stop
the Redstone launches you just have to
be constantly changing your tactics
it's impressive and sometimes you'll
have no idea what they're doing and then
you soon you certainly find out very
quickly resources
a while back we had somebody on our Dev
team use a strategy where they built a
bunch of what are called plant Golems
which are archers so they're very weak
but they do a high amount of damage and
he had 40 of them and he just ran
through our base ran around our Tower
and took out our entire Tower with such
a simple strategy and that's why we
still love playing it every day because
every game is different you never know
what's going to happen
foreign
[Music]
sweet
all right we'll probably be in Florida
on the 18th
[Music]
it's water time baby
let's do it
I am a big fan of Forza Horizon I
haven't been a motorsport person in a
few years I used to play hockey and
welcome but I still think they're very
impressive the team is hard at work
bringing you the next generation of
Forza Motorsports built from the ground
up to take advantage of the Xbox series
consoles this is the most technically
Advanced racing game ever made I believe
today I'm joined by some of our amazing
team members to show you how we are
making it look real sound real and feel
real
this is Forza Motorsport I always love
hearing about sound design in these
games same is called
thank you
at launch Forza Motorsport features over
500 cars for you to collect race and
customize with more than 800 unique
upgrades this includes over 100 new
Motorsport cars the most modern race
cars we've ever featured on our roster
racing is violent it's a battle on the
race track
the advancements in our physics model
are greater than Forza Motorsport 5 6
and 7 combined this makes our Driving
Experience more fun and rewarding in the
way the car accelerates corners and
brakes our materials and shaders
higher resolutions
Cutting Edge the wonderful paint I just
thought it looked really cool
our paints are sourced using a
spectrophotometer oh yeah racing games
like behavior on a Surface they get
intense this yields a paint model that
has a much more realistic light response
across color metal flake and gloss
damage and dirt buildup is unique to
each car it's now contextually aware and
more localized we simulate paint
thickness chipping and directionality
dirt accumulation is more realistic
Gathering more in the low pressure areas
like recesses and alcoves
tell the story the thing that I
disagreed with is when he said it was
violent and reflects the marks
this is our best sounding Forza
Motorsport ever and the first to be
mixed natively for immersive audio
formats like Windows Sonic and Dolby
Atmos
to create an immersive soundscape each
audio system has been rebuilt from the
ground up to deliver a new level of
Sonic depth and authenticity for our
players modifying car parts like your
exhaust and turbo change the car sounds
in Forza Motorsport just like it would
in the real world every car now has a
variety of sound possibilities based on
the parts you've installed Hardware
accelerated convolution Reverb
accurately reproduces how sounds in
Forza interact within an acoustic space
Dynamic that freaked me out surroundings
and creating a real benefit by
themselves man I don't like it
foreign
new features like our regional track
announcer system and improved Tire and
Suspension audio bring a new level of
realism I want to know you more about
this Regional we're Fortune Motorsport
like track analysis system what is that
retire squeal every engine lap after a
month it's got to be hot in the market
full-time because you say everything's
the best every time how do you convince
me that it's actually about a it's got
to be tough
Forza Motorsport launches with 20
environments built from the ground up
for this generation you'll get to race
on iconic fan favorites as well all new
to Motorsport locations including our
first in South Africa kyalami
we capture our environments to an
incredible level of detail when we
reference a track our team comes back
with over three terabytes of highly
detailed photogrammetry
through the power of the Xbox series
consoles we're able to use this data to
draw up to 10 times more detail than
previous generations you'll see Lush
trees dense grass and overgrowth
vegetation animated track life
physically based lighting and volumetric
fog effects and a fully procedural cloud
system that evolves organically very
cool very cool look alive sound alive
and feel alive with Cutting Edge visuals
and crowds consisting of tens of
thousands of fully animated 3D
Spectators so you're always immersed in
the pure spectacle of racing for the
first time in Forza Motorsport fully
Dynamic time of day with weather ensures
a constantly evolving Racing Experience
where no two laps ever look the same
meanwhile Dynamic track temperatures wet
driving surfaces
ensure that no two laps ever played the
same
I love the detail our talented team of
all it looks great built into kailan
fast forward tonight and the Vista is
truly breathtaking
see the distant light glows of the city
beautiful wow
yeah the logo itself creates visual
impact every time you see it thanks to
Ray Trace Global illumination which
simulates how hundreds of thousands of
light rays accumulate color as they
bounce between surfaces how did the logo
we're rendering all our environments in
4k 60fps with real-time Ray tracing on
track to create true to life whoa oh
that's cool with mirror and flat glass
surfaces that's very cool with the
incredible detail of a GTR rendering
features beautiful Forza Motorsport is
truly a generational leap ahead with
unmatched visual Fidelity and
authenticity
yeah I think uh soggy riches I think
marketing is racing games has got to be
just very tough because every year you
have to say the most Impressions which
means every year
and it's our most comprehensive game
ever with over 500 cars and 20
environments with more new race cars
than ever before
you can experience all of this in our
incredible new online racing mode and in
our all-new car building focused single
player career
we cannot wait for you to get your hands
on this incredible game
foreign
this does look very pretty but I'm never
surprised by it I mean it looks gorgeous
I feel like this is moving really
quickly
this video is not that long I mean it is
long rather
the one we've been going oh yeah I guess
we all kind of thought through it
okay this is the game I think people
keep telling me to play
yep that's me and you're probably
wondering how I ended up here well it's
pretty standard that's the most cliche
opening to a trailer of all time check
this out
music player in my chest it's powering
up my new robot arm
this is like with the beat this is the
outside of the gameplay
hello Sunset Overdrive
it's like a rhythmic
Sunset Overdrive type
why didn't the hell am I
looking the name's chai not defect so I
recognize this voice
we'll take down this company one boss at
a time
just so you know this looks really cool
[Music]
that's right yeah you have to
the beat is not consistent but you have
to type wait wait wait wait wait did
that say made by
Evil Within
what
oh it's Bethesda then profession
rock star
so I guess they just published it
Rockstar what the hell
I'm Shinji mikami Studio
thank you for all your support over the
years wow I'm John Johannes director on
hi-fi Rush
chill out it'll be fine
so everyone thinks of us as putting out
horror games like The Evil Within or
spooky games like ghostwire Tokyo but
this is clearly something totally
different yeah what the hell it never
would have guessed already leaked
fingers crossed we hope it's a pleasant
surprise
oh let's have some fun whoa this is very
cool wow
so we've been waiting for this for a
long time so let's jump in and explain
exactly what Hi-Fi Rush is I would like
to hear it
no you can't do that I'm a mini one
again no it's already a problem
[Music]
action game so it's a bit of a Twist on
your traditional action yeah okay we're
getting a lot of those recently some
attacks help create a living soundtrack
that means all your flashy moves stylish
and devastating combos add a layer to
the moon so it's not just movie though
it's not like it's percussion the better
you can connect your attacks and
abilities or it's not just percussion
that clearly is you are in total control
during combat but everything you do
syncs up like an awesome music video
dude this looks so cool
you play as chai
a wannabe Rockstar and victim of a weird
corporate experiment that lets him sense
the rhythm of the entire world pulsing
to the game soundtrack
[Music]
okay
as you can see this looks the world
around you and it's the key to combat
you looking for me your attacks will
automatically sink to land on the beat
making Hi-Fi Rush a super easy game to
start playing
however attacking on the beat leads to
combos that end with a musical countdown
we call a Beat hit think a big cymbal
crash at the end of a drum Zone like
this
Landing beat hits on the Chicago finish
that adds unique musical Flair and high
damage attacks
and The Crowd Goes I'm so impressed by
this I am very excited to play this
and I guess it's already out or it demo
is out
[Music]
um
anyone see the guy that did this
[Music]
how about we see it all in action and I
think he has like the same sort of like
Bring It On
dorky maybe cheesy dialogue that a lot
of people are disliking and other things
right now but
it works very well in animation I think
you're never restrained by the music you
can jump Dodge parry and attack whenever
you want using whatever attacks you want
it's not about mashing buttons
key here is feeling the beat
[Music]
Sam super raw Katie this looks so cool
progress isn't blocked by missing the
beat but you get rewarded musically and
mechanically for staying in rhythm
but you don't have to stay in with them
I guess
when we say everything moves to the beef
we mean it enemy attacks
scenes
dangerous obstacles
you name it it all varies into the music
creating an ongoing jam session of a
game
[Music]
808 your robot cat can
come to your shoulder and helps you find
that rhythm
but we also have visual guides to help
you even more
whether you're Rhythm Pro or not
so cool doing this
just based on the beat but it's like
he's using a guitar he's not trying so
it gets by With a Little Help from his
friends
literally does feel very Jet Set get up
slacker we've got work to do chai will
team up with unlikely allies to expand
his repertoire of moves both in and out
of combat there's peppermint breaking
barriers and juggling enemies along with
macarons smashing enemy armor and
knocking back at him tag teaming with
chai's partners and attacks opens up
huge possibilities for dynamic Combos
and over-the-top action
that's not bad
the extra help is handy because when
you're not fighting I like the animals
running around and wreaking havoc all
over van Blaze because there's one punch
Man game there isn't that [__] trying to
take you down you and your partners have
a singular goal in mind
taking down the bosses of vandelay
Technologies
besides wanting to erase that picture it
seems they've got something a little bit
more Sinister on their corporate agenda
you'll fight through each department to
take them all on each level with their
own musical spin on the Rock genre oh
yeah and then we have a showdown
just finished an hour ago how long was
it Timeless Productions is it short I'm
ready to crumble boss battles are
climactic set pieces varying from
straight up fights and musical minigames
to chase sequences
custom queries app to licensed music
from amazing artists well I didn't
realize that
high five Rush is like nothing we've
made at Tango before
and we think it's like nothing you've
ever played before either
it's a high energy feel good Rhythm
action experience very satisfying to
play
or I played a few hours of it but I
never I never finished it and I was
always like damn this game looks awesome
it looks like exactly my kind of game I
think it came out at a bad time
we are moved
[Music]
shop
um
foreign
[Music]
Rush tonight I love that I love that
they've done that full game
seriously and that not leaking is
amazing I wonder how long after the show
super impressive and yes it'll be on
Game Pass as well
we hope you enjoy playing it
super excited
you looking for me
it looks really cool man I'm gonna give
it a shot
mind if I join
[Music]
I ended up not liking Ghostbusters
but I love uh evil women
this is entertainment you're going out
with the trash
here's your project Armstrong path shock
and welcome to Vande Lake Campus
[Music]
hell yeah dude
awesome
looks really cool
and also yeah so I guess that's the one
that they didn't talk about beforehand
that must be so satisfying for that team
to have just done that like that and
managed to reveal it without spoiling
anything or any leaks like that's so
[__] cool
welcome to Hunt Valley Maryland and the
headquarters of zenimax online Studios
you just saw a cinematic teaser for the
cinematics online
Fable I'm pleased to review ESO necron
which will launch in June and is shaping
up to be one of the best updates to the
game ever
if you watch the teaser closely you saw
that necron will include one of the most
requested features in ESO a new playable
class called The Arcanist
it's only our third new class since
launch and we know you're gonna love it
the arcanus wields magic influenced by
Forbidden Knowledge and has unique
abilities never before seen in this
world
of course the experience of exploring a
new area of Tamriel was the heart of
every ESO chapter necron will unfold an
Eastern Morrowind not seen in an Elder
Scrolls game since 1994. where you will
meet new characters and enemies reunite
with some old friends explore a story
based around the return of a well-known
danger Prince might remember from the
Dragonborn Skyrim DLC
for those of you new to ESO we release a
new expansion called a chapter every
year chapters are essentially Standalone
games in ESO you would venture in a new
region of Tamriel I will not play you
don't have to wait for the middle prom
chapter to jump in so I got so many
amazing experiences you can enjoy right
now but I know you love games like
Skyrim and Oblivion you'll feel right at
home amongst the thousands of stories
unfolding across every region in ESO I
think it's still performing pretty well
does anyone who's played a classic Elder
Scrolls game knows
is all about those feelings when you're
fully immersed in the world
remember that feeling when you first
encountered a dragon
you've got it
into province
it's dragons
we're questioned if you are capable of
taking down a frost troll in Skyrim try
it for yourself and ESO
what about the moment you visited a city
in Morrowind that was built inside the
shell of a giant crab
for the Oblivion fans out there how
about another chance at taking on the
Colossal Daedric prince merun's Dagon
just like any single player Elder
Scrolls game you can have a blast simply
by following the main quest line
or seek out lore and learn more about
the world
come a Craftsman
go fishing
decorate and furnish your home
[Music]
customize your character
play it like an action RPG it's funny
they have to sell it when you're ready
so like we know how you don't give a
[__] about MMOs
run dungeons co-op with your friends for
great loot or just join a guild to chat
with others
possibilities in this virtual world are
endless yeah Morgan that's how that's
how players will immediately feel right
at home it's the silly suggestion
Community is one of the most if not the
most welcoming you have to charge for
things they make why would they we
invite expenses yes so give it a try not
even really like your own stories
there's no required subscription and
thousands of hours of content to dig
into solo dude I would also love how
late you were with friends oh and Fable
news that's what I want explore every
corner of Tamriel with no level
restrictions it's magical being able to
travel almost anywhere you please from
the moment you enter the world
ESO is available on PC and Mac in
addition to previous and current gen
consoles including a purpose-built
next-gen version for the Xbox series xns
with High Fidelity graphics and enhanced
performance mode I just want to know why
every fantasy it's on Game Pass
and starting today for a limited time
we're making all past chapters available
to explore for any player so everyone
can test drive all of our adventures
including our take on Skyrim Morrowind
Oblivion and much much I always thought
elsewhere was really bad we have so many
passionate and talented developers
and handcrafted Epic Adventures and I'm
immensely proud to be a part of it
believe me we have tons more to share
and I can't wait for the team to show it
all to you
join us after this show for the 2023 ESO
Global reveal where we'll go deep into
all things necron
that was seeing Tamriel
you guys miss that
I'm not going to do that thanks though
dude every RPG has big spiders it sucks
all right red full time I am ready let's
do it
this is the one I'm definitely the most
excited about I would imagine that's the
case swallowing up this place bit by bit
I love our team
bad until it happens
ma'am it's too late
but
there are people who can fight back
stick together
[Music]
is it just vampires left for dead
because if yes I mean we love playing
doctor right now I'll have a good time
with it but for the calm
seasons have been eclipsed do I think
are fantastic well for level design than
anything else or at least that's what I
love about things red ball is a story
driven shooter at its heart which can be
played single player or co-op with up to
four players
choose your hero each with their own
and form the perfect episode
at Arcane we make games where the world
itself is as important as the character
right hence my curiosity with redfall we
take an exciting step forward building a
lovingly detailed open world to deliver
our largest setting ever
every inch of our open world is
carefully handcrafted and packed with
environmental storytelling did you do a
good job of that too explore the streets
of a quaint Island Town from the once
bustling downtown to the haunted forest
to the decimated seaside boardwalk it
looks great closely detailed landmarks
obviously like sort of fortnight but
there are safe places on the island
where you can detail density
[Music]
okay here we're at the fire station one
of your home bases
this is one place you'll receive
missions from survivors
I need you to do the Old Lighthouse in
the bay
it's been used for over a century to
keep boats away from the coastline if we
turn it back on it's a warning to anyone
trying to come to redfall right now easy
right
well the Lighthouse Keeper is a real
[__] joined up with those cultists
and took the damn lamp with him
go Albert
well okay this does make it look there's
a vampire known as Oh Katie shrouds
blanket the area in darkness
disorienting their prey
they hurl lethal projectiles and can
even shift through so what kind of
seeing a single player gameplay right
now right like so this is something
something I can play solo
finish every Arcane game you know
it's cool kind of spooky
mm-hmm
the blood is a part of me and I am the
blood is that what that said
emo the fact that a vampire took the
time to write that damn dude
You Were You A Goddamn Edge Lord
so that was not scary but I'm guessing
implication is we will have some scary
moments or again will it sort of be like
left for dead where it's like
overwhelming scary not
an actual scary
oh cool
oh that's what the light was for I see I
see you're telling me how to do the
whole mission come on now
the lighthouse is back up but there's
more waiting for you taking down
vampires angers the vampire Gods who
will summon the Rook to take you down
is that a stone oh Big Boy hello
let's transition to what you'll find
outside of the main story missions
there's so much waiting for you redfall
is filled with encounters that can pop
up anywhere like this Brewery I don't
know man I'm just I'm still not really
sold it's gonna be one of those things
that like it's gonna be on game pause
I'll give it a try like our past
unfortunately in many different ways I'd
be happy to be proven wrong
hello Devin I'm all right thank you but
times be ready catching up on this as
soon as I had a chance to Remy uses her
combat robot reborn to help distract us
this weekend still streaming Dead Space
tomorrow and blow the game Jam it's been
a lot it's been a big week
the blood
foreign
yeah I think I I saw in a blog post they
said it was a little more Far Cry than
Left 4 Dead but I'm I'm not seeing how
maybe the open Wells the approach she
can take like entering certain areas is
more like a far cry encampment type
thing
that looked cool
okay so they're like floaters but
vampire
I love that animation like how quickly
explosion animation everyone's safe cool
let's move on
exploring redfall will take you beyond
the bounds of reality as you investigate
otherworldly psychic spaces to unravel
the vampire secrets that's cool
these deadly layers change each time you
step inside oh that's rad they look
really cool that's done Jacob sends out
his Raven to tag the enemies below Dev
follows up with his teleporter instantly
closing the gap
come on
to destroy a nest you have to take out
its heart and all of the vampires
willing to die I like to look at this a
whole lot
definitely gets the co-op vibes
thank you
so I'm guessing it doesn't really have a
story is also another thing I tend to
love about [__] games but
it'll be like one about vampire Secrets
I don't doubt they'll still do that but
um now Escape The Nest before it comes
I'm expecting you can do
not like a regular Lydia narrative
I really love Stephanie
nests aren't the only psychic spaces
you'll find dangerous pockets all over
the island
it's all vampire Turf so tread carefully
[Applause]
designs of the enemies are funny truly
be safe until the vampires are wiped
from the map outside the main story
another one of your missions is to take
back redfall neighborhood by
neighborhood
find safe houses hidden all over there
comes work your way up to the vampire
controlling the neighborhood
to reclaim this neighborhood you'll have
to defeat a powerful vampire
called the siphon
whether you died teach neighborhoods
each hero can take on any situation each
brings powerful unique abilities to the
fight and the upgrades you choose change
how they play
yeah I'd like a hint of something
to be upgraded to launch teammates for
Airborne it's often not really necessary
endless umbrella games ultimately like
again I played a lot of docties I really
enjoy it it's the energy back the story
there but I never play it by myself
which obviously I have with every other
Arcane game so
it looks like that's a good idea
so far
definitely think they're like locations
are Hero's ability tree to match your
playstyle 99.
damn where you get that kind of aim bro
come on now let's get some light on the
subject
let's hit them Arsenal there's a wide
range of Weaponry for military gear to
new vampire slaying inventions to sniper
rifles
well well
and of course there's also vampire
Stakes find these in the world to
customize your weapons
when you reclaim significant sections of
redfall the last step is to face the
underbossing controls or use to control
that neighborhood
under bosses are powerful Elites of the
vampire Gods with their own unique
abilities like this one's Shield
foreign
against the underboss you'll receive a
key of sorts
a skull that gets you one step closer to
facing the ultimate threat the vampire
God this is what I see a thieves okay
but then some of them kind of look like
raids I don't know to mix up a bunch of
stuff by the looks of things thank you
for visiting redfall and thank you for
all the support you've shown Arcane
throughout the years we sometimes joke
that our games can be tough to define
the one thing that's consistent we make
the kinds of games we love to play and
that's how redfall was born we Blended
everything we love here at Arcane Austin
immersive open worlds unique and
customizable heroes RPG and FPS gameplay
and of course our signature storytelling
and Rich World building I hope so along
with our spin on one of the most classic
monsters of all time vampires
it's been amazing to see how all of us
have pulled together to deliver our
vision for something new redfall is the
biggest most ambitious game we have
whenever I hear that I sometimes like to
have head first opportunity instead of
biggest and best we went like yourself
best thanks I won't have to wait too
much longer games don't all need to be
big
that's way sooner than I expected for
joining us cool see you very soon in
redfall here we go
it's definitely a nice thing about game
pause is that I'm like I don't have to
pay for it I'm gonna play it
still not totally shorter we'll see I'm
sure it'll be really fun
it's not what I want from Arcane but
that's just me I love their games with
such a passion
that it's difficult to live up to my
expectations okay we have three minutes
left
this is a really well-paced conference I
think I'm not blown away by anything
here
but I love when they talk to actual devs
I way prefer that than just marketing
oh okay this is a roast
um I like the length I like the
combination between gameplay and again
here in commercial devs I like this
conference a lot it's good
just yeah not blown away by any of these
titles but that's okay it's so much fun
to be working with Mo Yang studios
online excited about it at all times
definitely gonna be playing Red Bull
until it'll be one that I like get
um
everything looks really good they're
very different games they turn into
showcase some for everyone
forward to seeing one thing
Avid E3 at this point nice to have
something early in the entire server I'm
sure they'll probably be something right
[Music]
yeah it's pretty good thanks and see you
in Tamriel
definitely prefer
gameplay
all right let's do this
then boost the cinematic trailers
sometimes it's just way too much
[Music]
foreign
yeah thanks for watching Everybody
um we don't did it this will be live on
the channel I'll leave it up and for
anyone who missed it I'm streaming Dead
Space
tomorrow
almost today yeah at 5 PM PT
uh we have codes to give away with Sam
Siegel Kate's lion it's gonna be playing
more of the game
um come hang out come say hi and again
sorry I had to do this late my schedule
this week just got away from me it was a
very busy week kind of out of nowhere so
it happens
um yeah the stream will be for Dead
Space will be on Twitch I'm actually
thinking about maybe moving all of my
streams to twitch but I'm not sure just
yet
um I asked patreon and I just gotta
figure out how to do it um just because
they changed the way the live tab works
on YouTube and I think it's a little bit
confusing for people now so I might do
that I'm not sure yet like do everything
live on Twitch and then upload to
Youtube after still thinking about it I
don't know let me know
um thanks for watching everybody
I
wait did I say
Sam Siegel and Kate slowly did I say
that no surely not
Kate Siegel and Sam's William I might
have I don't know I'm tired
I will see you guys next time